Speaker 1: Ted Cruz went on a complete manic
tear yesterday during a Senate hearing with
the United States Secretary of Homeland
Security, Alejandro Mayorkas. This is Ted
Cruz auditioning for Fox News when Ted
Cruz wants to get himself on Fox News,
either interviewed or have his clips played.
He does these sort of manic scream fests with
oversize poster boards behind him. And
he certainly pulled out all the stops
yesterday. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: And in fact,
if you look at illegal immigration,
let's look at CBP encounters. You can
see 500,000, 500,000. It drops to the lowest
level and boom, what happens? You show up
and that red line is you.
Speaker 1: Now, let's talk about
that. A couple of different things here. This
they love this. They love to say the number of
encounters with Border Patrol went up when Joe
Biden became the president. Now, there are two
really important things to understand about that.
Number one, mobility in general was really, really
low during the pandemic. And in fact, you can see
that on the chart that Ted Cruz has behind him.
What we started to see was as the pandemic eased
and the weather improved, a huge backlog of people
who would have tried to cross previously tried to
cross the border. But here's the most important
thing. When encounters show up on this chart,
it's because the people were stopped. The people
were stopped. It if you were going to argue that
the borders are open and people are just going
through, you can't defend that by saying, look
at all these people stopped by Border Patrol. By
definition, that's because the border isn't open.
Speaker 2: That red line is Joe Biden and you're
claiming nothing happened. Oh, gosh, this was here
before us. No. You made the decision to allow this
to happen. Let me ask you, we now have
over 5.5 million people who've entered
this country illegally under Joe Biden. How many
murderers have you released into America? What
I'm not aware of any murder on wheels. So you
don't know, have you into. Senator, let me say
something. If you you know, if you take a look at.
Speaker 1: Now and this is Ted Cruz not actually
wanting to get answers about anything. This is a
performance piece and a pretty bad one at that.
Speaker 2: No, you don't get to give a speech.
Do you know how many murderers you just. I'm
just trying to answer your. How many rapist have
you released? Senator, I'm trying. You know, you
can answer. I know. Or I don't know, Senator. Any
individual who poses a public safety threat. How
many child molesters have you release and removed
into the United States from the United States?
Speaker 1: And this word of releasing is
straight out of the Trump playbook. Trump has
been insisting, quote, Mental institutions are
being emptied out and released into the United
States. Of course, that's not happening.
This is a try out. This is a performance.
Speaker 2: So your testimony under oath,
subject to perjury, is that you have not
released any murderers, rapists or child
molesters among the 5.5 million. Is that
your testimony? Mr. Chairman, may I have the
opportunity? No, you may not. You may answer
my question. You're you're not. Is that your
testimony? Yes or no? You're not allowing me
to answer you? I am allowing you to answer. I'm
not allowing you to filibuster. If you take a look
at the the pace of immigration in 2018 to 2019,
you're refusing to answer. Let's move on. Let's
move on to. Got a ways.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
This is not how you learn anything. This is not
how you fix anything. This is not this is really
nothing. This is not it's not of any value. Here
is more of it. Of Ted Cruz just losing his mind.
Speaker 2: These are modern day leg irons
because these are children being sold.
Into sex slavery. And you don't even know what
they are. That is astonishing. Mr. Secretary,
how many children have been sold into sex slavery
under your administration? We are taking it to the
courts. How many children have been sold into
sex slavery in a Do you know how many children?
Speaker 1: I mean, how many were sold under
Trump? The idea that because the number
isn't zero under any administration, that it's
this particular individual's fault is absurd.
Speaker 2: Sold to sex slavery to an unprecedented
degree. Mr. Secretary, I want to say to you
right now, your behavior is disgraceful.
And the deaths the children assaulted,
the children raped, they are at your feet.
Speaker 1: And what about all of the ones under
Trump? Given that this is a global issue, it's not
about minimizing. It's well, it's very capricious
and arbitrary. For Ted Cruz to be indignant
when Biden is president, but to never have said
anything about the exact same thing under Trump.
Speaker 2: If you had integrity, you would resign.
And I will tell you, the men and women of the if.
Speaker 1: Ted Cruz had integrity,
he would have resigned.
Speaker 2: Border Patrol, They've never had
a political leader undermine them. They despise
you, Mr. Secretary, because you're willing to let
children be raped to follow political orders. This
is a crisis. It's a disgrace. And you won't even
admit this Human tragedy is a just crisis.
Speaker 3:
Claiming one minute Chairman
time. Mr. Secretary, would
you like to respond to any of those questions?
Speaker 2: What the senators said was revolting.
I'm not going to address it.
Speaker 1:
I mean, he's like, Why bother?
Honestly, why bother? Why bother?
This is of no value or meaning. That.
Is Ted Cruz desperate for relevance,
excited about the possibility of being featured in
compilations on Fox News of what happened at the
hearing that he is just screaming and doing the
sort of Lindsey Graham routine. That's the that's
the sort of routine Lindsey Graham, the Republican
senator, did during the confirmation hearings of
eventual Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh,
scream and act indignant and be furious at people.
And it probably does make it on to Fox News,
but we see through it. It's completely pathetic